Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
When we show a photograph to someone, most
of the time we are interested in sharing our
memories.
Graduation, family festivities beautiful landscapes
are common examples of this.
With the recent ascendancy of these amazing
neural style transfer techniques, we can take
a painting, or any other source image, and
transfer the style of this image to our contents.
The style is transfered, but the contents
remains unchanged.
This takes place by running the images through
a deep neural network, which, in its deeper
layers, learns about high level concepts such
as artistic style.
This work has sparked a large body of followup
research works.
Feedforward real-time style transfer, temporally
coherent style transfer for videos, you name
it.
However, these techniques are always about
taking one image for content, and one for
style.
How about a new problem formulation where
we paste in a part of a foreign image with
a completely different style?
For instance, if you feel that this ancient
artwork is sorely missing a Captain America
shield, or if Picasso's self-portrait is just
not cool enough without shades, then this
algorithm is for you.
However, if we just drop in this part of a
foreign image, anyone can immediately tell
because of the differences in color and style.
A previous, non-AI-based technique does way
better, but it is still apparent that the
image has been tampered with.
But as you can see here, this new technique
is able to do it seamlessly.
It works by first performing style transfer
from the painting to the new region, and then,
in the second step, additional refinements
are made to it to make sure that the response
of our neural network is similar across the
entirety of the painting.
It is conjectured that if the neural network
is stimulated the same way by every part of
the image, then there shouldn't be outlier
regions that look vastly different.
And as you can see here, it works remarkably
well on a range of inputs.
I hope these scroll animations come out really
smooth and creamy.
This video took a long time to render in 4K
resolution with 60 frames per second, and
was only possible because of your support
on Patreon.
If you wish to help us create better videos
in the future, please click the Patreon link
in the video description and support the series.
To validate this work, a user study was done
that revealed that the users preferred the
new technique over the older ones in 15 out
16 images.
I think it is fair to say that this work smokes
the competition.
But what about comparisons to real paintings?
A different user study was also created to
answer this question.
And the answer is that users were mostly unable
to identify whether the painting was tampered
with.
Excellent work.
The source code is also available, so let
the experiments begin!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!